[Music]
my son comes on the radio or something
and i'm like everything is about you
it's always there
they've always been about you she goes
what do you mean i'm like like they're
all about you
like every song i've ever wrote she was
in disbelief
of the fact that i was writing music
about her but the funny thing i liked
saying this is like
i was 16 years old and i might have
heard through
somebody that she had maybe like or
had some sort of feelings for somebody
else and then i would go and write a
song like
darling i'm not trying to ruin your
happiness but don't you know that i'm
the only person for you in this entire
world
and like these heart-wrenching songs
about
a myth when i say that it's not just
about i've always
you know wanted to be in a relationship
with you she's always been
a real friend she's always been a
genuine friend of mine and
i don't know i think there's something i
mean actually i do know after
living with her family i know that she
was raised in like this in the most
amazing beautiful
family style and that's why she's been
that way
i was 15 when the world put me on a
pedestal
i had big dreams of doing shows and
making memories
made some bad moves trying to act cool
upset by their jealousy
lifting me up
i think the second i heard him sing on
the record i was like god i'm not going
to be able to sing that high
it was hard it was very hard to sing
that high
i have to say singing with justin bieber
is no small feat
and i like the fact that you were both
intimidated by the other one
isn't that isn't that so human
it's so human and it's so interesting
and then you meet and realize it's just
another person and it's completely fine
it's just another person who's suffering
just as much as you
and going through their own just as much
as you and that's the case for every
single person
[Music]
we have four dogs at her house um but we
just got a puppy his name's tarzan and
he's 10 weeks old
and uh it's i'm excited because he
is he's like he's this he's like this
big now he's growing really fast
and i'm taking him back home to canada
in five days so he's gonna meet my
parents and sister
dual nationality very important very
important
he's half latin
you